all right a couple of media stories that
I want to discuss with you there is a
very interesting realignment happening
in the wake of Tucker Carlson's firing
from Fox News and of course the Dominion
nearly 800 million dollar settlement
obtained from Fox as well as the firing
on CNN of CEO Chris Licht after only a
year which included a number of very
strange programming decisions a Newsweek
is now reporting MSNBC dethrones Fox
News after years-long ratings dominance
Fox news's years-long streak of raiding
dominance has ended with new data
showing it's seeding the top spot to its
rival Network MSNBC Nielsen data
regarding the week ending this past
Sunday was shared on Twitter by AJ Katz
a reporter specializing in the cable
news business according to the data
Fox's Prime Time 8 to 11 pm Eastern
viewership averaged
1.504 million the average viewership for
the more left-leaning MSNBC over the
same time time frame average
1.52 million narrowly beating out the
conservative Network that has long been
a leader in cable news viewership there
are a lot of important things to discuss
here first and foremost this is a very
small margin of victory for MSNBC and I
do want to remind everybody that I
couched this story not as I'm cheering
about MSNBC MSNBC is a corporate media
Outlet just like all the others that has
chosen a center-left very establishment
Democratic party editorial position it's
well to my right it's not super exciting
there's a media story here and I want
people to understand that it's a media
story totally separate from my
particular political views
MSNBC is being helped significantly
right now by number one the Fiasco and
disaster at Fox News in which Fox was
exposed in court for lying to their
audience in order to uh get ratings on
the basis of playing koi and in many
cases overtly supporting Donald Trump's
false claims that he won the 2020
election to further conservative talking
points to maintain access to Republicans
in power by repeating or allowing them
to repeat uncritically their talking
points that has been really bad for Fox
News the firing of Tucker Etc we then
have CNN CNN with a disastrous year with
now fired former CEO Chris Licht at the
helm and so MSNBC truly has benefited
from problems suffered by Fox News and
by CNN what this actually means for the
future of 24-hour news media remains an
open question with fragmentation of the
audience thanks to streaming and to some
degree Independent Media like our show
and so many others that are available
asynchronously online in podcast YouTube
Tick Tock Etc form
with a desire
from audiences
for a different type of presentation
that maybe feels a little less corporate
and a little more intimate in some way
this little blip in which Fox is down
and MSNBC is up may remain or it may not
as far as cable news ratings are
concerned but my prediction is that
other forms of news media and political
analysis are going to continue growing
as a share of the total news media
audience now you might say well David
you would like that right because you
benefit from that we're doing fine
already we don't need to grow anymore
everything's fine it's it's and I'm not
even saying the David packman show is
what's going to grow necessarily it's a
question about the direction of people's
tastes and appetites and there's a real
question mark now the next 18 months or
how many months do we have 5 and 12 17
months the next 17 months not even 16
and a half months leading up to the 2024
election are going to be extraordinarily
important in seeing what niches
different media Outlets choose we don't
know what fox is going to do from here
on out we also don't know what MSNBC is
going to do but very interesting
nonetheless 30 million trees are
destroyed every year for toilet paper in
the U.S alone so toilet paper is a big
contributor to deforestation and climate
change our sponsor real paper makes
toilet paper from bamboo bamboo plants
keep growing which means no
deforestation bamboo also absorbs five
times as much carbon from the atmosphere
as pine trees and bamboo toilet paper is
stronger than regular toilet paper and
even softer so bamboo toilet paper is
all around a win for you and for the
environment it's time to move on from
that toilet paper from trees that you're
using at home when you use real paper it
doesn't feel like you're sacrificing
anything it's soft and fluffy and
they'll ship it to your door in plastic
free packaging on a schedule super easy
with every box of real paper you buy
they are funding reforestation efforts
across the country through their
partnership with one tree planted so
unlike the toilet paper that cuts down
trees real is helping to actively plant
them go to realpaper.com Pacman and use
code Pacman for 30 off your first order
and free shipping the link is down below